Anh lưu báo xung mười gây mươi lớn cáo sải trong nhiều ngày qua tại đi bàn tình thành quyền.
Lâm nước xâm cầu rất cao, đây gần tới đoạn đe bối, cuộc cuộc tổ bán đe bà phương phân này cùng tình thành quyền, bị bởi sáng nay.
Ngay sau khi sẽ ra từ cố, chỉ cửa đi phương cộng các hưởng vũ trang, đã cần chương trình khai ta cố,
đã bảo ăn toàn chúng người rất bà tình bàn xâm.
Xe cố bói đe bối xâm cầu, đã khiến trình nước xâm trang và phí trang, gây gặp lụt cục bộ hồ số tính đường,
và khu tân cơ tọng bàn xâm, cuộc phân này phung.
Các biển pháp, in phó đã được chính quyền để phương cận chương trình thái,
bối sự phó hợp tích cửa lực lượng vũ trang, dân quận tự vệ và các quân tệ tại chốt.
Đồng thời thông báo trong người dân hạn chế đi lại gần cố bộn quyền, đi chuyển tại sang để mang toàn.
Đến khoảng 5.8 mưu vũ, Ngay 1.5 mươi, Rõ đe bối bị bớt, đã được lực đường chức năng cơ bản ra cố,
ngăn nước trang vào phí trang.
Theo đại phí trự vệ bán tình thái quyền, mất nước trên các thông phải đi bàn đã giảm gần.
Tuy nhiên chính quyền và lực lượng chức năng, văn tiếp tục ứng trực theo dõi chạch chế để chủ động các miệng pháp ứng phó.